What do you say when you start to cry in
an argument? I'll tell you.
Absolutely
nothing. Don't you dare for 1 second
start to apologize
for the fact that you're starting to cry
and you're tearing up. It is exactly
what your body is meant to do. And in
this episode, I'm going to break down if
you're the person who's tearing up, what
to do and say, what not to do. And
second of all, if you're the person who
on the other side, somebody's starting
to cry in front of you, what you can do
and what not to do. It is an episode
that is going to touch everybody because
we're humans. And if you're human,
you're going to find some value in this
podcast. Welcome to the Jefferson Fisher
podcast. If you're listening and find
any value and and the advice that I
give, I would be absolutely honored if
wherever you're listening, you can
subscribe or follow. It'll take 2
seconds. And my promise to you is to
continue to put out this type of
content. Okay, when you go into that
moment, all right, I want you to
picture. Maybe you're you're at work.
Maybe you are in conversation with a
spouse and you're talking about
something that is tension-filled.
All right, keyword on tension.
And it doesn't mean that just the
content is tense. It means the room is
tense. It means you're already feeling
something. Maybe you came into the
discussion already at 50% tension,
right? It it Or maybe it's 80%. You've
had a day. You have a lot on your plate.
Somebody in your life has passed away.
You had a really hard morning
uh at the house. Maybe your kids were
going crazy and people weren't being
nice and it's just it's already 9:00
a.m. and it's been a day and you're just
ready to go back to bed. You know how
You know what I'm saying? And when that
happens,
understand that there's this window that
you have left of just to be able to
regulate yourself cuz you're already
starting to feel that pressure, that
tension rise. And you get into that
conversation
and whether it's the content, the
feeling, whatever it is,
and and all of a sudden
physically, you can tell that your eyes
are starting to water.
They're starting to water.
And right there in the tear ducts, you
can feel it, and your face might get
flushed. Maybe you're having a hard time
with your breath and you're you're
having to swallow it down.
And really cuz you're you're just trying
to calm yourself. What do you do in that
moment? Here's exactly what I'm going to
break down for you. For anybody who's
who's struggling with this, or if you
know somebody who struggles with this,
and you want to be a help to them, this
is the episode for you. First, I'm going
to talk about what to do if that's you,
you're the person who's feeling that.
And two, how do you handle it when
you're the other person and they start
to cry in front of you. There's some
do's and don'ts that we're going to talk
about. Here's what I want you to do.
Number one, if you start to cry in an
argument, you cannot, you will not
apologize.
That's when you say, "Oh my gosh, I'm so
sorry. Oh my Oh my I'm I'm being
ridiculous right now. Oh my gosh, please
ignore me." Stop that.
No. That's a no. We don't From here
forward, listen to me. From here
forward, we're not going to be doing
that.
We're not going to be doing that. We're
not going to use any of that language.
When you're in front of somebody and
that starts to happen, it's not I'm I'm
so sorry. I I apologize. And you just
you you feel like all of a sudden you're
a puddle on the floor and you begin to
have to
Really, what you're doing in that moment
is you're trying to now manage their
comfort.
Because you're feeling like, "Oh, now
they're uncomfortable and I now have
committed an error and I now have to
apologize for it. I've done something My
body has done something that I now have,
you know, caused a grievance of their
miscomfort, discomfort, and now I have
to apologize for it. That is a wrong way
of thinking.
Your body does this naturally.
Naturally. It is biological. It's a It's
a physiological response when
you feel that come up to the top
and it's it's releasing. And what that
is is a release. It is tension. So, the
higher the tension, the higher the need
for release. And you know what that is?
It's a wave. It's going to pass. It's
going to pass. You're not going to cry
forever. Those Those tears are not going
to come out forever. Um I mean, it's I
don't even like really calling it
crying, because to me crying is when you
you actually have to set aside some time
to go through these emotions and process
this. Most of the time, those kind of
conversations, there's it's not so much
crying as it is it's a it's emotionally
overwhelming and stimulating to the
point of your tear ducts operating,
doing what they're doing, cuz your body
is saying, "Hey, I feel all that
tension. Let me help you. Let me just
You know how if you have like a bottle
of soda? Up north, they call it pop.
Whatever that's about. We call it down
here in the south, we just all call it
Coke or soda, whatever. And you
and you start to You know that it kind
of fell over on the table or whatever
and it kind of got jostled around. You
You're opening it for the first time.
And what do you make sure you kind of
like
You have to let that pressure, that air
pressure out. Because if you don't,
what's going to happen? It's just If you
open it, it's just going to It's going
to erupt. It's going to erupt and it's
going to spill everywhere. Your body is
protecting you from the spillover. It's
saying, "Let me let out a little bit of
pressure for you. Let me I can tell that
you're tense.
It needs to happen. So, hear me.
It's not that you're weak. It's that
your body is doing exactly what it's
made to do. All right? I get so tired
of hearing these naysayers that are
like, "Oh, no. If you're at work, you
can never cry. Like they you they can't
see you as weak, right?" Toughness was
never about dry eyes.
Toughness is about your actions, your
words, what you say from your chest,
what you do, the next move, the next
conversation. It toughness has nothing
to do about how dry your eyes are. There
are people in my life, men, women, who
when they have a show of emotion, and
I've seen it, even the toughest men in
my life,
they show just a little bit of emotion,
and they have tears, I admire them more,
I respect them more, I say, "Wow, they
are really somebody that encompasses
what it means to fully express as a
human."
We're humans. We're meant to be doing
this.
Okay, man, I was really going on there.
I was feeling I'm feeling myself for a
moment.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
Where were we? Don't apologize. Don't
apologize. You don't need to do that.
Here's what I want you to do instead.
Number two.
Before we go to number two, actually.
Yeah, you're like, okay, Jervis, hold
up. I need to make sure that you know
this. When you say the things like, "I
I'm being ridiculous." or "I'm so
sorry." or "Please ignore me." yeah,
you're now calling attention to the
crying rather than staying your
attention on the conversation. And now
the other person now kind of feels
obligated in a awkward way to now talk
about it of like, "Oh, no, no, you're
you're fine. You're you're you're good.
I mean, oh, you do you need to stop? Do
we need to And now it's become the thing
you didn't want it to be, which means
it's now the center of attention.
The more you call attention to it, the
more attention it's going to bring. We
don't want that. So, instead of
apologizing and commenting in a way
that's going to make you feel less,
instead, this is what I want you to do.
Now, we're going to go to number two.
You ready? Number two, instead of the
apology for crying, I want you to name
and label your tears.
All right, that means you're going to
say something like, "These are tired
tears.
These are tears that care. These are
frustrated tears. These are overwhelmed
tears."
Just that alone, okay? Label exactly
what kind of tears they are. These are
grateful tears.
Right?
These are These are happy tears. These
are sad tears. Label the emotion. Label
what these tears come from.
Right?
Way better in terms of being short,
concise, of just saying, "Ah, this is
what happens."
The phrase I love to to use, and some of
you have probably already heard this,
and it's worth repeating. What I love
is, "This is my stress in liquid form."
That's what tears are. They They are
your stress in liquid form. And when
you're able to say that to the other
person and continue to go, meaning
you're going to say, "These are tired
tears." Meaning you can wipe them away,
and you just keep going. You keep
talking.
You keep talking.
Don't Don't If If anything, you need to
just breathe through it. Take some
breaths.
Be okay in 5 seconds of silence. You You
owe yourself at least a breath
to to compose yourself and and continue
to to talk. Go, "No, I'm I'm I'm good.
Keep Keep going." And and continue on
with your point. Or,
"Where were we? All right, back to what
I was saying." And you're and you're on
it. Okay, rather than, you know, I just
I hate this about myself. Oh my gosh.
Nope, that's that's diverging away.
We're not going to be doing that. So,
name and label your tears. It is It is
something that is going to show
ownership. It's going to show emotional
maturity. It's going to show that, "Hey,
I know what my body does. This is what's
happening, and you don't need to be
focused on it. You continue to focus on
me because what I'm saying matters." And
toughness has nothing to do with dry
eyes. It has everything to do
with what you say next. You with me?
Before we keep going, I need to tell you
about Cozy Earth. Now, if you've been a
listener of the podcast, you know that I
love Cozy Earth. Why? Because everything
they do is top-notch premium. I'm
somebody that likes to wear not not
something that's overly, you know, fancy
and also not too casual, somewhere in in
the middle. And Cozy Earth hits that for
me every single time. Now, their
clothing is not just amazing. It is also
their pajamas. It is also their bamboo
bedding, which keeps me cool at night.
It is their towels. It is their house
shoes, for goodness' sake. My mom is
crazy about their pajamas. Everything
they do is good quality, and that is
really hard to find, in my opinion, when
you're asking for really comfortable
clothes. So, go to cozyearth.com.
Whatever you get, it's not going to
steer you wrong.
Use code Jefferson for up to 20% off.
cozyearth.com/jefferson. Use the code
Jefferson for up to 20% off. And now,
let's keep going. All right, number
three.
If you are the person
If you're the person
that tears come to them and you go, "Oh
my gosh, what am I going to do? What am
I going to and it feels awkward for
you?" Here's your chance to really level
up, to rise up and show yourself to be
different than other people. Instead of
you stopping everything and going, "Oh,
are are you are you okay? Do you do Do
you need anything?" I know you're trying
to show your intention is trying to show
care and comfort, but at that point,
what you don't realize is it's making it
worse because it's the very thing they
don't want. That's the very thing they
don't want. Don't become another thing
that they have to manage. Now, they have
to manage your emotions and your
comfort. Instead, you need to see it as
something that their body does as a
function, just as yours. And if you if
you feel so inclined, feel free to grab
a tissue box, but do not grab the tissue
for them and don't hand it to them.
Bring the box
and offer to them and they can pull the
tissue, right? But you You need to be
trying to, "Oh, do you Do we need to sit
down? Oh, do we need to uh take a break?
That that is you're taking away the
strength that they have.
You you're taking away their own
decision, their own autonomy to choose
what they need to do. All right, and and
for you to
kind of say all right, well, now you're
on crutches in this conversation and now
I'm going to treat you differently.
You're missing the plot. Okay? So, when
somebody is doing that and they're
tearing up, don't call any attention to
it.
What you definitely don't do is say, oh,
this again? Oh, really? God, okay. Can
we just talk without you crying?
You you go go stick your head in a a
ditch. Don't do that. All right, don't
don't do that. Okay? There there that is
not what you need to be doing. If
somebody is saying this again, oh, you
always cry.
You're not being a kind person. In fact,
that's that is a sense of control, that
is belittlement, that is everything that
you do not want to be and showing any
kind of empathy or respect for the other
person. All right? So, if you find that
the other person in front of you starts
to tear up, don't change what you're
doing. In fact, if you can, just
continue to talk as if they are not.
Don't bring any attention to it. Just
continue to talk normal as if they are
not. If you need to, maybe talk a little
bit slower if you feel that that's right
for the moment. If it's if it's
something that even if you decide
that the moment calls for
hey, I'm I'm good if you we want to take
a break for a moment. Maybe maybe you
want to offer that. Again, it's going to
depend on the person
uh depend on the context and and what
feels right,
but do not, please, do not, for me,
say, oh, okay. Well, um are you are you
okay? Like I'm I'm I I can just you
know, we don't have to talk about this
and make it make it worse. I understand
it's it's good intentioned that usually
that that tends to
make things worse.
And I I I do want to say it's not a
uh
it one size fits all possible
exceptions to every conversation where
somebody is is tearing up because yes, I
I need to include this. Yes, do some
people use tears manipulatively? People
do and they learn it at an early age. My
daughter, my son, they definitely do
that. They can work up the tears, know
that it can possibly probably get them
closer to what they want and then whoop,
it dries up just like that. And there
are people that maybe you're dating or
you're in a relationship with that they
can use tears in that way. That is all
the more reason for you not to stop,
time out, put on the brakes and start to
console and comfort.
Right? Because that's kind of what
they're wanting in that moment. It is a
much firmer response to
continue to nod and talk and say I'm I
know it's okay.
You just just let's I'm you're
continuing on in the conversation.
You're not you're not allowing that to
be a distraction or a break. You
continue to engage in the conversation.
Now, if somebody's wanting to bring up
something collateral to the
conversation,
it's okay to say, "Hey, I'm absolutely I
I hear that and I want to talk about
that as soon as we finish this
conversation." In other words, you're
not letting the tear the tears derail
you, distract, or somebody's trying to
you know,
really detract from the point because
they're trying to use those tears in a
way they're manipulative. I didn't I
Fourth time, I didn't get it. Uh they're
trying to control you in some way. So,
that's definitely something to to have
some discernment about. Bottom line,
if you tear up in a argument or a hard
conversation, there is nothing wrong
with you. In fact, it is everything
right about what your body is doing and
what it means to express feelings as a
human. You are meant to feel all
feelings. All parts of you are good and
fine and perfect and just as they they
should be. It is okay.
It is okay.
And for those who say
it's makes you look weak,
there there is some history there of why
they might be saying that.
I can tell you for the people in my life
that I've seen tears, it has only made
me love them and respect them
more. It is not about the tears. It is
about while I'm having the tears, what
I'm choosing to say and my actions
around it. That is what shows whether
you are tough or whether you are weak.
It is what the words you use and the
actions that you take place next. That
makes all the difference. So, no
apologizing. We're going to label and
name the tears. It's your stress in
liquid form.
That's it.
That's all we got. Thank you for
listening. All right, try that and
follow me. Be good.